recording in progress I am with simply
learn
we are the delivery partner with IIT
Concourse for this program
a professional certificate course in
data science
so let's talk today about how this will
help you develop your data science
career
and
our agenda today covers
a little bit about you because I'll be
asking a few poll questions
along the way we'll talk about data
science and the careers in the field
and we'll talk about what this program
from IIT com Port offers you how it gets
you job ready
and enrollment steps for those of you
who are interested I'll try to cover
your questions in the Q a so if you have
questions that come up along the way
please put them in the Q a function of
Zoom
and I will address those
toward the end at the Q a session
let's get started with careers in data
science
so you're all here because you
understand
that data drives the economy
we have gone through a period of global
upheaval we were watching the world
transition to a digital environment
for a number of years over the last
several decades but within the last
three years since the pandemic started
that transformation has accelerated
tremendously
there was an executive from a Silicon
Valley venture capital company
who said at the beginning of the
pandemic if they had told us
we needed to transfer transition
everyone here to work from home
um we would have told them it would take
six months
and cost 10 million dollars
when it actually happened we did it in
three days was no budget at all
and so this gives you an idea of
kind of upheaval in the scale of the
upheaval that we've all gone through
many of year now working remotely or had
been for a period of time uh you went to
non-contact ways of doing business
with uh people you buy things from
or sell things to and
all of that
moving onto your mobile devices even the
trends before the pandemic with uh
fintech and
transactions on your mobile devices all
of that generates data
all of that data is potentially useful
the businesses
so they need a way to deal with the
flood of data the extremely high volume
of data and the fact that the data is
coming from sources they hadn't
anticipated in their original business
planning
an example from an American fast food
restaurant Wendy's
I had the
Chief marketing officer
looking at the data coming in from the
mobile application that they developed
for the pandemic
and realizing that he was now able to
see consumer behavior in much more
detail than he had been before when
people were just ordering verbally from
the drive-through window or going to the
counter now he has digital trail of what
a consumer
prefers what they order what they
literally Buy and they can tailor
marketing efforts to the individual
consumer based on that data
but in order for them to do that they
have to have people who can draw
business insights out of the data
who can help them
tame the massive data a lot of data and
turn it into actionable
advice predictions and insights
the amount of data that
you have to deal with in the world
is
far greater than anybody could have
anticipated
IDC says 175 zettabytes by 2025 but
that's a prediction that probably is a
little out of date and the number maybe
several times higher so
we look at the
scale of spending on data analytics and
data science
on Big Data
understanding of data
and it's
skyrocketing
size of the industry continues to grow
and demand
for industry Specialists and data
Specialists data scientists continues to
grow there's a lot of different paths
you can take
in
data science
so
you can of course become a data
scientist which is a
long-term path takes you through the
applied and theoretical background
looking into the statistical
underpinnings of
data modeling
and creating algorithms you can be a
data analyst
where you focus on application of
data models to
create insights and provide data to
Business Leaders or or policy makers
you can become a big data engineer or
architect
or you actually focus on the collection
and conditioning and
organization of data for use by data
scientists and analysts database
administrator which is also a
focused on the technical aspects of data
organization and Storage
can become a business developer business
intelligence developer I should say our
analysts so applying data analytics to
business problems in particular
statistician looking at
qualities within the data and providing
information about patterns to the data
scientists and analysts who will turn
that those patterns into models you can
go into the artificial intelligence
realm with artificial intelligence and
machine learning you can go further into
deep learning
and you can be a manager of the
analytics process
and providing
kind of the traffic controller of
providing information to the users
so a lot of different places you can go
in a data science career but to do that
you have to really have
uh up-to-date skills across the board
need to understand how to design
algorithms
to understand principles of data
warehousing organizing big data so that
it's usable by
algorithms and analytics you need to
understand the different types of
analytics predictive
prescriptive and descriptive you need to
understand the way that the data is
extracted and processed and turned into
knowledge we need to understand the
principles of machine learning
so
we've talked about these paths I think I
went backward
um
so all of these and being able to do
visualization of course and telling the
story
that the data tells Translating that
into a form that the policy makers or
business business managers can use
let me ask this first question if I may
this first question is
what is stopping you from
taking management certification
oh sorry data management certification
sorry
what's stopping you from becoming a data
scientist
being certified in this area
I'll leave this open for
about 20 seconds more
you can put in as many of the uh issues
as apply to you
is it because you can't find a
curriculum that covers all the skills we
talked about is it because you don't
feel you get the Practical experience
you could use to demonstrate your new
skills
is it because of the way that most
programs teach from pre-recorded
lectures
or is it
um
a Time issue for you
and
I'll close the poll in five seconds
and here we go
here is the result the major objection
most people have in this audience is
wouldn't get the Practical exposure you
need
uh to be able to show
yes I have used these new skills and
here's how
um
Venom people also
mentioned the other issues as well so
I'm going to share with you how this
program
addresses those issues the professional
certificate course in data science from
IIT Contour the QR code will take you to
the
program page if you're interested to
have that up but the duration of this
program is 11 months
it requires about 10 hours to 15 hours a
week
because there are weekly live classes
and they're held on the weekends
the rest of the time you can access the
learning management system
24x7 so you do not have to do all of the
work on a fixed schedule
of the class schedules are set for four
hours Saturday four hours Sunday but
other than that you can do your projects
your Labs your reviews all of that on
whatever schedule fits you best on
whatever device you have
uh use your desktop your laptop you can
access videos on mobile devices as part
of the program so
you're able to study wherever and
whenever you have the time
and the cut the curriculum is very
comprehensive and I'll detail that in a
bit
it's aligned to the needs of Industry so
IIT confer has designed this program so
that
you will end up qualified for jobs
within
industry based on the requirements that
they've received from different
employers they work with
um
the
weekend classes are online are live you
have instructors who are lecturing to
you live and taking your questions live
you can interact with them
um and they can take you through
exercises and projects and coding
exercises um
directly
so that you have the chance to get
immediate feedback if you have any kinds
of doubts or blockers that come up
and
I mentioned the entire program other
than the scheduled classes
is on your time on your schedule so
you can do this alongside your school or
work obligations
but
10 or 15 hours a week total for that 11
month duration
the end of the process you receive a
certificate that's issued
uh by melting IIT camphor jointly
through their e and ICT Academy
art of IIT compar and this certifies
that you've completed the course gained
the skills
and they're willing to attest to that to
anybody who asks
you have applied online learning along
the way with industry experts with the
faculty members instructors you have on
the Hands-On projects and integrated
Labs that you do within that same
learning environment
um that includes a final Capstone
project that ties together all of your
skills so you can demonstrate to future
employers or your current employer what
you've learned and the fact that you're
now fully capable of using those skills
and along the way also you get master
classes from IIT conference faculty
um
for those of you who are not familiar
the Indian Institute of Technology
Concord was established in 1959
so the same year that I was established
it was it is currently the home of a
number of major national initiatives in
technology including the national
blockchain project
and the interdisciplinary Center for
cyber security and cyber defensive
critical infrastructure
and
the
reputation of the University of The
Institute is
um
extremely high
this is the reason why it's been
interested with these
major
critical initiatives
the professional certificate course
gives you the master classes from The
Faculty the Capstone project
and the certificate and
having the name of this institute on
your resume
is a prestigious accomplishment people
will recognize
we talk about the eligibility if you are
interested in taking this program
you will need to meet certain
eligibility for prerequisites
the main one is having a bachelor's
degree
to be in a related field and it needs to
have 50 percent marks or higher
um
related field meaning you have to have
some prior prior knowledge of of or
experience in programming in mathematics
so you'll need to have taken some
college-level mathematics have some
experience in programming which can be
formal or informal
and you do not have to have work
experience but is highly and strongly
recommended that you have at least two
years of formal work experience
in the in the real world not necessarily
in technology it could be in any type of
work but work in a formal setting so
um
you have an understanding of how
organizations work and what their need
for data analytics and the products of
data Sciences
so with that I'm going to ask another
poll question
and this one
is
based on your experience
to get a feel for who's in the audience
today are you currently in
school or
are you in the workforce
and leave this open for another 20
seconds or so
and
I'll end the poll now because the
numbers will stop changing so
we have about 55 percent of our audience
are people who are currently in school
maybe a little early for you to enroll
in this program but I'm glad you're
learning about it
um for the rest of you you are eligible
from the work experience standpoint and
um I see that a number of people here
who have more than five years of
experience so
I'll share with you how this program can
help you move your career ahead
if you're at that level as well
let's talk about how this program
prepares you
first thing we'll talk about is the
curriculum
the curriculum consists of a set of core
courses and and projects
and a set of electives
the electives are available to you at no
additional cost
they're based entirely on how much time
you want to put into the program and
which ones interest you
but let's talk about the Core Curriculum
first
there's an induction session
the induction session is just an
orientation to how to use the learning
management system when the class
schedules are what to expect in terms of
your overall curriculum how to move
through it basically all the things you
would get in uh so to speak of freshman
orientation for using this online
education system
you move into your first course with
your live classes in statistics
Essentials for data science so
statistics being the underlying
principle of how to use data
to uh
gain insights into the world
statistics that describe what has
happened describe what is happening and
describe what is likely to happen based
on patterns of data that's the
foundational course
from that you move into a programming
refresher so that if you don't have
recent or extensive programming
experience you don't need to worry this
will be
a course that gets you back up to speed
the next course shows how to use python
in data science applications
python is of course an important
language
um from that you'll get exposed to the
principles of machine learning
and how algorithms can use data to
refine their
um predictions and
they're models
you'll go into a tableau course Tableau
is a tool for data visualization
and data
analytics data science is only valuable
if you can communicate
findings to people who are
maybe not
familiar with data science principles
themselves Tableau helps you turn
data into
visual representations that lay people
can understand
and finally the data science Capstone
which is about a three to four week
course
to do in under the mentorship of one of
the instructors
and this is where you pick a problem to
solve
create your own solution implement it
your instructor will make sure that you
stay on track and don't
run into any blockers or doubts and that
becomes essentially the final exam for
the for the entire program because that
will be evaluated
and uh determine they
earn your certificate
let's look at the electives along the
way the master classes
happen monthly you
highly recommended you get exposure to
The Faculty talking about their uh
particular areas of expertise
practical courses among the electives
you can
business analytics with Excel
so still being one of the most widely
used tools for doing
data analytics and presentation you get
you can choose SQL training to
understand how
the database principles work for
management of data you can choose power
bi to go into another tool for business
intelligence and visualization you can
study the r programming language for
data science which is a
very powerful combination and you can
get exposure to some of the more
advanced
Ai and machine learning topics like on
natural language processing and speech
recognition
fascinating area so all of those are
available to you at no additional cost
based on
your level of interest and effort
number of different
tools that you will use and you will
need to be able to show that you can use
them proficiently in order to be able to
complete your coursework and your
Capstone project
so at the end of this program when you
list these on your resume you will have
actual examples of the work you've done
with each of these tools in order to be
able to
demonstrate improve your proficiency
with them
things like Python and the different
libraries like numpy and sci-fi for
processing
different kinds of data analytics
problems the r language I mentioned
um things like matplot live and pandas
for
visualizations
tensorflow for machine learning
Tableau for visualizations all of these
are part of the program
I'm going to talk about different um
we talk about different projects and
here are some examples of the types of
things that you will
um do perhaps as Capstone projects
Mobility as a service
so working on the kind of problem that a
company like uber would face uh
a company like
Mercedes-Benz and times the data science
problem in manufacturing Walmart for
their data science for uh
problems in retail and predicting their
seasonal sales patterns e-commerce
held their recommendation engine works
and how you would recommend to improve
it
Telecommunications
looking at ways to improve the customer
satisfaction for a provider of
cable and internet services so these are
the types of projects that you'd be
presented with that you can choose from
and that
show how you use your new skills to
solve real world industry aligned
data science problems
and that is for the Capstone
you'll be doing a number of projects
along the way in each of the courses
but when you reach the Capstone phase
you'll focus on one project that you've
chosen
maybe from those previous five and
you'll come up with your approach to the
solution
you'll Design Your solution you'll
implement it it's about a three to four
week process
and once you complete that you'll submit
that to your instructor for evaluation
showed that it does what
your objective was and and that it works
and
based on that you'll be able not only to
earn your certificate but you'll be able
to take that project in future and when
you are in interviews or evaluations for
a
new job or a promotion you'll be able to
say here's an example of the work I do
but this is a really important
part of the program that gives you
practical experience that you can use to
demonstrate your new skills
so I'm going to let this gentleman talk
about the learning management system
itself he's going to use an example of
one of our other university partners
simply learn works with or their digital
marketing course but the principles of
the learning management system are the
same you'll see how the environment
works and what the experience is like
there are two components that make our
online bootcamp approach so successful
great content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically hold on for just a
moment I want to make sure that you can
actually hear that
I'm gonna
fix this
just realized I may not have shared the
sound
there we go
let's start that over
my apologies
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp
Camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn you set the course
timeline that meets your busy work and
home schedule and keep track of your
progress every step of the way we'll
help you stay on plan with automated and
24 7 human support at the core of our
programs are our live virtual classrooms
where you interact Real Time with
trainers that are recognized leaders in
their field there you'll review key
Concepts get questions answered and
interact with your peers the important
reports on the audience if you notice
are demographics this is super useful
especially if you're running ads for
example to conclude on social media
later you'll learn social media
marketing too
by looking at these numbers you'll be
able to understand the age range of
people that you should be targeting you
know what you could just focus only on
that age category show your
advertisements to them very useful
that's not all you get to learn from
faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes ask
your questions to top industry leaders
in exclusive ask me anything sessions so
Rising session of Google Trends and
optimize it okay so let's go back to
here right here where it says web
searches and you can see that there's
going to be the YouTube searches okay so
now you can see that the YouTube
searches is going to be so there's a
option uh under not just web search and
there's going to be a YouTube search
okay so just go ahead and click on
YouTube search and you should be able to
optimize your search results
so what is Instagram app Instagram
when we come across any sort of
Instagram apps would appear within those
video contents so you would be caught
when you are watching an original video
and leave you a video app and then go
back to the original
content
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice tackle practical
problems with multiple projects and
simulations and work on a real world
Capstone project that you can showcase
to Future employers your learning isn't
restricted to just live classes explore
our highly effective self-learning
videos and other resources to fine-tune
your learning and remain up to date
always you can focus on different
learning approaches by subject to
personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn so
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
so just to recap what you saw
the learning management system allows
you to manage your curriculum
let you see the full learning path
you're going to go through and what step
you're on keeps track of which modules
you've completed
takes you through that path in a
defined sequence
gives you the live virtual classroom
environment to interact with your
instructors
gives you the environment and what you
do your labs and projects on a virtual
machine so that you don't have to have
separate set of Hardware software that
you maintain lets you do all your tests
and assessments in that same environment
including
the Capstone project and
it keeps track of all of your project
progress I should say through the
different courses electives unlocks the
certificate for each of the courses and
the final certificate for the program
itself
along the way you have the ability to
access 24x7 support for the platform
where the subject matter you can
interact with your peers in a community
forum
and you can
interact with your instructors between
classes via email through the system so
all of that is available to you again
24x7 throughout the process allows you
to
work on
your education in the time that you have
available in your schedule
with that
introduce
professor
moment
Professor kakari is the
Poonam and Prabhu gold chair Professor
endowed chair professor in the
department of computer science and
engineering
and he is the program director
responsible for
designing the curriculum putting
together the program overseeing the
master classes
um so he has uh Stellar reputation and
responsible for making sure that this
program meets your needs and the needs
of potential employers and Industry
we can talk a little bit about learner
outcomes
the people the graph on the left shows
where people have come into the program
from what industries certainly a number
of them from Information Technology but
also from Banking and finance from
software products uh arm and Healthcare
retail manufacturing
um
because it's true that almost every
industry
has the need for data science
talent and assistance in drawing
information inferences and insights from
data on the right you see some of the
companies that are out in the
marketplace actively hiring for data
scientists
and
these include of course many
multinational corporations throughout
India you'd find a number of the major
corporations in India as well so
this is a
remains an excellent career field
um
before I move on I want to mention that
we do offer
well let's move on
are you interested in enrolling the
program based on what you've seen so far
based on just what you've seen
let me ask that question
and we'll leave this open for about
another five seconds
and here is the result
almost 85 percent of our audience
that they are interested so you are
interested in
enrolling in the program so let me share
with you the process for doing that
the enrollment steps
because simply learn is a delivery
partner with IIT concour for this
program
you will email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net and what I'm going to
try to do now is put that email address
into
the chat so that you can find it quickly
and
let me make sure I get that to everybody
all right
so use to email us we will take a look
at your information request from you
documentation of your
educational background
uh we'll request from you documentation
of any work experience you have
we may administer a couple of simple
tests about
your math and programming knowledge
and assuming that you pass that review
we will send you an admission offer
so
the next classes start February 22nd the
section
uh we we have several inductions before
each class cohort one of them was today
so I'm not sure when the next one is but
it will be within the next few days
probably uh early next week
um and that will be as I mentioned just
the orientation to the program when you
roll but the actual formal classes start
on 25th February
cost of this program is one lock thirty
five thousand seven hundred
inclusive of tax
and we offer no cost financing where you
can pay the cost of the program off a
monthly basis
so you don't have to put up the entire
sum up front
if you are ready to to enroll
contact us and ask us at simplylearn.net
if you are looking to do this sometime
in the future
um
contact us anyway and we'll keep you in
in the loop informed about future
cohorts so let me share this with you
just to get a feel for
how soon people would be interested in
rolling
I'll leave this open for another 15
seconds
and I'm going to close the poll at five
and there you go
half of our audience are interested in
enrolling either in the cohort starting
this month or the ones starting in March
or April
um they do
recur frequently
and
for those of you who are looking to do
to enroll
further down the road please keep in
touch with us by contacting us at ask us
at simplylearn.net
and we'll be able to answer any
questions you have and then
move forward when you're ready
point I'm going to go in and take a look
for the questions that you put in
here with me for a moment as I
hold on a second
oh
there we go
okay
looking through the chat to see if I've
got a
question there and then I'll look at the
Q a
so we have a question from the chat a
number of you asked if you get a
certificate of attendance for this
webinar and I'll tell you how to get one
of those if you if that's something
important to you
let me move down
duration of the course we talked about
which is 11 months
and
let me go into the Q a here
just
pardon me
a little issue with
the webcam placement
move here
there we go
sorry about that
okay
what is a data analyst
a basic question but that's actually a
very good question there's
several aspects of
data science
so this course
covers data science in or general sense
that we talk about
um
the
principles of Statistics how models are
constructed
then how to use the models how to
present data with visualizations
how models can be self-teaching through
machine learning
um can be exposed to different topics of
deep learning
and
all of this covers
the broader subject of data science
data analytics data analysts
are applied
practitioners in data science they take
models and
tools that are built by data scientists
and use those to process data on an
ongoing basis to create insights for
their consumers
um
data Engineers focus on
the technology and methodologies for
capturing and organizing data so it can
be used by data scientists and data
analysts
and
artificial intelligence and machine
learning specialists
look at
advanced
algorithms and Technologies so that the
models can become
self-teaching and all of those are
different aspects within data science
um I hope that answers that question you
have a question uh from
uh just a honey I'm a chemical engineer
with 12 years of work experience in
primary aluminum smelting
what is the future career for me if I
pursue data science
now you have a number of different uh
options
to deciding um
data science in your industry can be
used in the process Improvement area to
understand
things like statistical process control
quality control
where to find new methods and ways to
improve efficiency of production
um data science can be used in the
Metallurgy
if you want to move into a different
domain data science is a set of skills
that you can use in
translate into other work domains if you
want to move into a different industry
so there's a lot of great opportunities
both within your current sector and and
field as well as
opening up other possibilities for you I
hope that answers that question
is it Giants is necessary to master
coding of any language to join in this
data science course
if you have any cutting background that
will be suitable for you to join the
course during the course you will be
learning python
and you will also have the option in the
elective to learn our programming for
data science specialized language for
data science so I know you don't have to
come into the program knowing a
particular language just have to have
some experience an aptitude for
programming
another question is it free of cost I
think we've covered what the cost is
have someone who's already enrolled in
the Mastery class in data science I
think you're going to find that that
covers a lot of the same material you
probably wouldn't want to duplicate that
um but again you can contact our
learning Consultants at ask us at
simplylearn.net and find out if there
are uh important differences
um
I have a career breakup
Anya says I have a career break
can
you can he continue his course after
this uh continue his career after this
course
so the important thing is that if this
is going to give you a new set of skills
that's going to give you a new set of
skills that you'll have
demonstrable experience with with the
Capstone project this may open up new
opportunities for you the fact that you
have a career break is not necessarily A
a
limiting factor for this program so
again contact our learning consultants
and ask
their advice on that
um
what is the difference between this and
the master class so Master Class covers
a lot of the same material however this
course offers access to the IIT camper
faculty through the master classes uh it
offers their curriculum design and the
certificate is issued by them so this
program
has a different Focus
and the different cachet to a different
quality to it and so
um
this is again going to give you the
kind of endorsement of IIT concour in
the form of their certificate
I have 18 years of experience I have an
anonymous attendee 18 years of
experience on the non-tech side
am I eligible to learn and grow in this
profession
um so in order to get into the course
you don't have to be a technologist
you do have to have the aptitude
and basic experience and programming in
mathematics and we will offer you an
assessment test on that to see if you're
eligible to enter this course and there
may be other options if you're not
prepared for this particular program
you may be able to help you with other
options but
um certainly people who are not
technical
move into the Technology field
very very commonly and succeed well so
uh there are
tools that that uh
this course and other programs from
Simply learning can offer you that can
help you make that transition you may be
able to give you Preparatory courses
that will prepare you to enroll in this
program
so again contact our learning
Consultants
um
similar question uh post certification
is there a job placement guarantee there
is not a job guarantee however
um
at least check one thing quickly
don't want to offer you wrong
information about the program
you just quickly check one thing
I apologize
yeah
one thing that we offer is career
assistance
so for six months after you earn your
certificate we will give you access
to Career assistance through IIM jobs
which is our partner in India for the
career assistance program
that includes access to their
exclusive job board but more importantly
includes resume preparation services
where you will be working with a resume
writer to go through your resume a
couple of times and rewrite it so that
it is suitable to pass through
automated tracking systems and AI
filters and so that is still suitable
when it appears on a hiring manager's
desk to attract their attention
um and the second the third element
after the job board and the resume
rewrite is the one-on-one interview prep
service that they offer which is a
service where you get to meet online
with there
interview preparers and go through
several rounds of interview preparation
be able to handle phone screens with HR
to be able to handle the technical
interviews with technical managers who
are going to evaluate you for jobs and
to handle management level interviews
for your ability to be a team player and
fit in with the culture of the company
and so you get the ability to do a
one-on-one mock interviews and prepare
for each of those all of that is
available to you from the six months
after you earn your certificate
this is all to help you with your job
search although it is not a job
guarantee program
hope that that helps you
silver Roy can we call ourselves data
scientists after the completion of this
course
um
in a certain sense yes you can call
yourself data scientists because you
will have studied data science
um
you will have a grounding in the
principles of data science
so you will be data scientist
um
data science data scientists engage in a
lifelong education
and so you will want to look into if
this is a if your goal is to become a
data scientist at a high level within
organizations
you'll want to look at further education
Beyond this program
um
simply because that's
kind of the the
career trajectory and the educational
trajectory for preparation
ongoing work in data science
but you will have the the
foundation and the background to be able
to call yourself a data scientist
um
will this course benefit a machine
learning and computer Communications
research scholar
and
the the answer to that question is what
level of
work are you currently doing in the
field and
will this be additive to that will it
give you a more rounded set of skills it
will take you deeper into machine
learning
um so you'll want to to contact our
learning consultants and look at our
syllabus but
this can
this can be a help to you
um
the career options I typed I think I
talked about in terms of all the
different paths you can go within data
science machine learning
into engineering
uh
nagaraji s uh I'm a banker
with 12 years experience how can I step
into it
uh
with Masters in data science so a
program like this can help you make that
transition with your background in
banking you have the domain experience
you understand the needs for data
science in that field and you understand
the challenges
that Banking and Financial Industries
need to solve with data so having the
background from this program will let
you start working on those problems
pretty quickly
um and so this is a good program for
making a transition of that type
um
a person who says I do not have coding
or language experience only Excel and
you make a career of data science so we
noticed in Excel that you've used a
number of tools
for charting for
finding patterns and graphing them and
that type of thing and you also have
other data manipulation data management
Tools in Excel and so it's a it's got
some of the basic qualities for data
Analytics
and so you have some exposure there they
want to take
a programming class an actual online
coding class
on a very simple level in order to
prepare for this course but you would
want to ask the
learning Consultants that ask us at
simplylearn.net find out if your
background is suitable for entering into
this program or what preparation you
might want to take to get ready for this
program
um but if you have a desire to enter
into the field of data science and
have a aptitude to grasp the concepts
um then yeah you can be successful in
this career
and you get presentation
um last question
so yes we will send you an email with a
copy or a link rather not a copy of but
a link to this recording
so that you are that able to
um
review this
access material so expect that email in
a couple of days
with that
to check the chat box for a moment
all right
yep
um so
with that we've reached our time and I'm
going to conclude the webinar with the
last question
share that
so if you need help
with getting enrolled final questions
let us know and also answer yes to this
if you would like to get a copy of a
proof of attendance certificate for
today's session
so if that's something that you would
like to receive
kick yes here
and if you would like help from our
lending consultant tick yes sir
I'll leave this open for just another 10
seconds since it's a yes or no question
five four three two one
about 40 percent
but with that I want to thank everyone
again the QR code takes you to the
um
web page for the program
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
to ask questions and get the enrollment
process started
and on behalf of IIT contour and simply
learn I would like to invite you all to
join our learning community
that concludes our webinar for today
thank you so much